[Musica]
Quando ho letto il programma di
quest'anno di questo Telex Ho subito
pensato a Jennifer Lopez Leonardo Di
Caprio sarà che non brillo sul tema per
ottimismo Però l'idea di salvare questo
pianeta Boh
e quindi mi è venuto in mente
immediatamente da un Look up l'avete
visto Ve lo ricordate per chi non
l'avesse visto un minimo spoiler alla
fine butta talmente male la situazione
sulla terra che la presidente Meryl
Streep decide di fuggire su una
navicella eccezionale super tecnologica
insieme altri 2000 passeggeri ibernati e
per atterrare poi chissà quando su un
pianeta extrasolare per l'appunto da
ricollonizzare
fantascienza Non lo so ma il punto è chi
sale a bordo di questa astronave
politici tanti familiari pochissimi
Qualcuno addirittura ha lasciato a piedi
in maniera un po' distratta
finanziatori tantissimi qualche
scienziato Ecco visto che faranno poi
una minaccia fermiamoci un attimo Ma voi
se poteste scegliere chi portereste su
questa astronave per andare a
colonizzare questo pianeta B ok
per cercare di esplorarlo per cercare in
qualche modo di abitarlo per creare
delle solide basi per una civiltà
duratura Ecco devo dire che Sentendo i
miei predecessori qui su questo pacco
porterei tutti loro e porterei
sicuramente un musicista ma convinto
Assolutamente Morello scienziati medici
porteremo sicuramente qualcuno che
sappia costruire un architetto ci serve
di sicuro qualcuno che sappia lavorare
manualmente qualcuno che sappia magari
cucinare con quello che trova qualcuno
Sarà che sono intriso di cultura Pop Ma
quelli come me che sono cresciuti con i
telefilm degli anni 80 Probabilmente
stanno pensando proprio a lui a MacGyver
ex sportivo laureato in fisica un
coltellino svizzero un po' di nastro
adesivo e ti risolve qualsiasi tipo di
soluzione
del resto apro una parentesi da un
sondaggio del 2007 cioè 2007 e 15 anni
dopo la trasmissione dell'ultimo
episodio di MacGyver in un sondaggio
fatto negli Stati Uniti è venuto fuori
che è proprio lui proprio MacGyver è il
personaggio da cui gli statunitensi
vorrebbero essere Aiutati in caso di
emergenza
anticipando precedendo soggetti del
calibro di Indiana Jones James Bond Lara
Croft Ecco Insomma un posticino per
MacGyver probabilmente ce lo portiamo
però attenzione che il nostro mitico
Angus MacGyver si chiamava esattamente
Angus come la razza bovina Ecco è
certamente una bellissima risolutore di
problemi però lo è in un mondo noto Ok
In un mondo che lui conosce come conosce
la cassetta degli attrezzi che ha sulla
sua Jeep
Ma dove la sua improvvisazione anche il
suo problem solving più creativo il suo
pensiero laterale e all'interno di un
prevedibile sistema di causa e di
effetto
la sensazione è che se sarà quando sarà
non sarà un film di cui saremo passivi
spettatori ma dovremmo essere forse più
simili a un videogioco in cui saremo
spettatori
ok E allora prendetemi per matto ma
insieme a tutte queste figure
eccezionali io un posticino sulla nostra
astronave per un game Designer sì
proprio quelle figure che sviluppano
giochi e videogiochi Ecco lo troverei
Non lo so è che se penso a questa
impresa incredibile no di andare su un
pianeta lontanissimo l'abbiamo visti
anche stamattina
affascinante immaginate Che casino ecco
io un posto per una figura che ci possa
dare
uno slancio diverso forse la porterei
anche perché la sensazione è che
finiremo di nuovo per continuare a
credere che tutto vada per il meglio che
le cose possano bastare a se stesse gli
psicologi questo lo chiamano un
ragionamento motivato ma è motivato da
noi stessi cioè attenzione Siamo noi che
forziamo il conosciuto il reale per
farcelo tornare ok Un po' come pensare
che la tecnologia da sola basterà a
salvarci
Ma che dovrà utilizzarla questa
tecnologia che dovrà gestirla chi dovrà
anche programmarla questa tecnologia E
siamo sempre noi e il nostro
funzionamento è molto meno lineare molto
meno razionale di quello che ci piace
credere a questo punto Galimberti ci
direbbe ci Morirebbe anche ci direbbe
attenzione
perché se la tecnica diventa il mezzo
con cui possiamo raggiungere qualsiasi
cosa e diventa essa stessa Lo scopo
e a questo punto in un mondo in cui
anche governato la tua tecnica in cui
fondamentalmente anche una domanda sul
sul fine sugli scopi diventa totalmente
inutile ma capite che a questo punto non
c'è più spazio per tutte quelle che ci
piace chiamare huma skill Ma c'è
soltanto spazio per una vana e vaga
professionalità Ecco siamo certi che
questa vana e vaga professionalità ci
possa bastare sul pianeta B oppure gli
facciamo fare presto la fine del pianeta
ma soprattutto un po' Come il nostro
McGuire Perché cosa succederà Quando
dovremo confrontarci con qualche cosa di
totalmente Ignoto qualche cosa che che
ribalta il modo con cui pensiamo di
conoscere il mondo
a questo punto facciamo un passo
indietro
da anni ci sentiamo dire che viviamo in
un mondo buca che per chi non lo sapesse
significa volatile incerto complesso e
ambiguo Ecco ma poi vi immaginate quanto
potrebbe essere buca questo pianeta di
Forse però non tutti sanno che questa
espressione buca in realtà nasce nel
1985 per mano di due economisti ben il
nanos ora 1985 avevo quattro anni e il
mondo era già buca ora forse si tratta
di accettare il fatto che forse tutto è
sempre buca ok e si stabilizza la
situazione soltanto quando diventa
storia tutto ciò che invece viviamo nel
qui ed ora è ancor di più Quello che ci
aspetta e per ciascuno di noi
semplicemente una grande avventura
un'avventura caratterizzata da
fluttuazione turbolenze altro che Travel
gum di quelle che non possiamo
comprendere non riusciamo a comprendere
neanche se ci sforziamo
un'avventura con talmente tanti fattori
da considerare tutti sempre più connessi
tra di loro che l'analisi dei dati è un
labirinto
con informazioni complete
contraddittorie che prendetevela voi la
responsabilità della presa di decisione
Ecco un'avventura volatile incerta
complessa ambigua Come sicuramente
esplorare un pianeta B Ma come anche
tutto il nostro quotidiano come la vita
nelle nostre aziende
un'avventura da cui L'unica cosa che
sappiamo è che usciremo trasformati
E allora dobbiamo per forza parlare di
cambiamento un concetto talmente abusato
che anticipo le scuse soltanto per
riproporvelo possiamo subirlo esplorarlo
cambiare o lasciarsi cambiare come
facevamo da bambini quando con le spalle
una base sicura che in qualche modo ci
attendeva ci supportava anche ci
stimolava
riuscivamo a esplorare qualsiasi cosa
riuscivamo a sperimentare
Pensateci Provate a rifletterci un
secondo cercate di ricordare Alla
scoperta di quelle primissime sensazioni
suoni colori
da neonati con quei sonagli e poi tutto
in bocca
e poi ancora alla scoperta di quello che
iniziava a piacerci le prime autonomie
del pallone mio e gioco soltanto che
voglio io del collezionare pezzi di
carta adesiva chiamarli figurine e
sognare e dargli valori fantastici
Alla scoperta di quello che ci faceva
battere il cuore di quello che
apparentemente ci muoveva per niente
dei problemi
da risolvere di quelli proprio da
evitare delle sfide delle classifiche da
superare da scalare dei Big Boss da
eliminare Alla fine per poter dire
veramente di aver vinto Ecco vi
ricordate quei momenti ce la facciamo a
ricordarli chiudete gli occhi è facile
stavamo giocando
stavamo percorrendo quello che qualcuno
definisce il sentiero giocoso della vita
stavamo giocando stavamo volutamente
cercando di superare ostacoli non
necessari ecco Ma siamo proprio sicuri
che questo sfidarsi non sia più presente
o addirittura hazzardrei essenziale
all'interno della vita adulta
della nostra vita quotidiana e
figuriamoci sul pianeta B
Ecco allora torniamo un attimo sulla
nostra astronave in partenza
siamo sicuri che in questa incredibile
avventura che ci si prospetta non ci
serva qualcuno che sappia essere tanto
esploratore quanto base sicura da un
lato qualcuno che non abbia paura di
quel foglio bianco dell'ignoto e che
anzi lo affronti con testa da psicologo
braccia dal progettista cuore da bambino
qualcuno in grado di individuare che
cosa ci Motiva che cosa ci coinvolge
e per poi ricostruire tutto questo in
un'avventura significativa ma al
contempo base sicura
una sorta di Master per trasformare
tutto ciò che noi viviamo in un video
gioco di ruolo
del resto è a chi non piacerebbe avere
compagni di questa avventura che siano
motivati coinvolti che sappiano
affrontare magari anche le sfide col
sorriso
Però questo non avverrà per magia ma sta
a guardare i nostri gruppi quotidiani i
nostri aziende i nostri lavori
non avverrà per magia Ci vorrà qualcuno
che sappia introdurre dosare queste
dinamiche e meccaniche
Ma attenzione ve lo ripeto non voglio
portare su questa astronave uno
psicologo come me voglio portare un game
designer uno sviluppatore di giochi
ora attenzione
vi dico una tale banalità che non
servirebbe scomodare Harvard
però caso vuole che proprio l'università
di Harvard indichi come per le persone e
collaboratori soddisfatti riescano siano
in grado di portare al gruppo entro il
quale si muovono il 31% di produttività
in più
Ora è chiaro che sulla nostra astronave
Per far sì che queste persone siano
soddisfatte Ci vuole un ambiente
favorevole un buon clima una giusta
ricompensa ad esempio
riprovarci avere una seconda chance Non
è proprio male come ricompensa
ci sono tanti fattori Ma se vogliamo che
i nostri compagni d'avventura diano
veramente il 100%. Beh dobbiamo lavorare
su quei fattori legati alla cosiddetta
motivazione intrinseca obiettivi
riconoscimenti sviluppo personale
Progresso responsabilità dovremmo
costruire un percorso che dia un
significato più ampio un afflato epico a
quello che facciamo
l'avrete capito come fosse un gioco di
quelli triplava sì perché il gioco come
la nostra spedizione è un sistema
composto complesso Certo ma composto da
un certo numero di elementi legati tra
di loro
che deve interagire con tutto ciò che
non è parte di questo sistema
apparendo dimostrandosi sempre un
tutt'uno all'interno del gioco come
nella nostra spedizione Ci saranno dei
conflitti ci saranno dei conflitti
naturali crescenti e di varia natura nel
gioco più o meno avrà sempre la
caratteristica di una simulazione sul
pianeta B la cosa potrebbe diventare un
pochino più rognosa tutto è o dovrebbe
essere definito da regole
in grado di indicarci che cosa si può
fare che cosa non si può fare e poi a un
certo punto dobbiamo avere un risultato
dobbiamo essere in grado di capire
quando è finita e come è finita un
risultato chiaro
ma soprattutto così come un gioco
necessita dei giocatori per uscire dalla
logica del Meggetto polveroso sulle
nostre scaffali come ad esempio quel
Trivial con cui non giocate da anni così
come
il gioco ha bisogno dei giocatori così
il nostro la nostra spedizione avrà
bisogno dell'equipaggio per diventare
una vera esperienza avrà bisogno di una
squadra di un gruppo
disclaimer d'obbligo Io lo so che
giocare il gioco non è La Panacea per
tutto e se qualcuno c'è rimasto
giustamente sotto a Alice in Borderlands
Quit game qualche domanda anche critica
se la sta facendo
però fidatevi in mezzo a tutte le altre
figure io un posto sull'astronave per un
game designer
non è ancora chiaro il perché sarò
ancora più diretto allora
semplicemente perché con le sue
conoscenze con le sue competenze il
nostro game designer può trasformare
fruitori di un servizio in giocatori
perché il suo lavoro è anticipare e
disegnare degli scenari che noi neanche
riusciamo a fantasticare
perché incertezza ambiguità sono il suo
habitat naturale e nella volatilità e
nella complessità ci sguazza
è una figura sicuramente ibrida
complessa che ancora troppo spesso viene
soltanto declinata e immaginata
nell'ambito dello sviluppo di un gioco o
di un videogioco e invece parafrasando
una nota pubblicità e tutto intorno a
noi l'abbiamo già visto anche negli
interventi precedenti
al gioco al mondo del gioco stanno già
guardando i musei le pubbliche
amministrazioni le scuole le università
le aziende per fare che cosa per
coinvolgere le persone per motivarle e
per avvicinarle e per trasferire
informazioni
una figura in grado di trovare quel
giusto equilibrio tra apprendimento e
divertimento in grado di soddisfare di
appagare anche quell'omo lubens che
esiste dentro di noi
e che però schiacciamo quotidianamente
dentro il grigiore della routine
non dimentichiamoci anche un altro
elemento importante
che è già il noto game designer per
l'appunto Eric zimmerman Nel 2014 ci
ricordava che fondamentalmente tutti noi
Saremo chiamati a diventare dei veri e
propri game designer intendendo che cosa
intendendo un concetto molto semplice
ovvero che ciascuno di noi sarà chiamato
a padroneggiare durante la propria vita
quelle meccaniche quelle dinamiche ma
direi più che altro quelle sintassi e
quelle grammatiche ludiche
per cercare di far sì che il nostro
quotidiano diventi un qualche cosa che
valga la pena vivere
grammatica e sintassi da spettatori
spettatori dicevamo da spettatori
spettatori
del resto come la musica anche il gioco
non è soltanto un passatempo ma è più
che altro un vero e proprio linguaggio
che varrà la pena custodire anche nel
pianeta B Grazie
[Applauso]